Speaker 1: And you know what else, by the way, is
not working for Republicans? Having Rick Scott,
senator from my state down here in Florida,
running the National Republican Senatorial
Committee, now the National Republican Senatorial
Committee, the NRC, is also the fundraising arm of
the Senate Republicans. And they've got a problem
right now. The problem is they all want to know
where the heck the money has gone because they
have raised $173 million this cycle. It's a lot of
money and they got a lot of contentious races out
there that they need to be spending this money on.
There's just one problem. It's almost all gone.
Rick Scott apparently bad with money still.
And I'll expand on that still in just
a moment. But the Republican Party
in the Senate now only has $28 million cash on
hand. Like the situation is so bad that last week,
again, right as we're heading into general
election mode, they announced they were
withdrawing $10 million worth of ads in
crucial swing states. Like Pennsylvania
and Wisconsin, two seats Republicans
desperately need to hold on to.
But right now, polls are not looking so good
for them. And they had to pull out their ad buys
because they only have 28 million. They're not
going to go blow another 10 million, you know,
a third almost of what they've got left on two
races. So the big question these Republicans
want to know right now is, Rick Scott, where is
the money? What the heck have you done with the
hundred and what, 50? Some odd almost million
dollars? Where is it on? So far, no answers.
But I think it's important to point out the fact
once again and I'm sure most everybody knows that,
but it seems a little relevant here, right.
Rick Scott, before he got into politics,
was a businessman, was a businessman that started
a health care company, a health care company that
later on down the road would commit the largest
to date Medicare fraud in the history of the
United States, over $1,000,000,000. And the
fraud was apparently so bad that Rick Scott,
in his deposition, had to plead the Fifth
Amendment, I think something of, what, 75 times?
I know that's not as much as Trump, you know,
having to plead it 440 times in front of Leticia
James a couple of weeks ago, but 75 times pleading
the fifth. So you don't incriminate yourself into
that massive Medicare fraud. That's a lot.
And so somewhere. Somewhere along the lines.
Somewhere down the road once
Rick Scott got into politics.
Governor of Florida for eight years. Now he's in
the Senate. Republicans looked at him and said,
hey, remember that time this guy's company oversaw
the biggest Medicare fraud in history? Right.
Clearly, they can't be trusted with money at all.
What if we put him in charge of all of our money?
And then wouldn't you know it?
All their money disappeared.
Now, before anybody jumps to any conclusions.
Please understand, I am not in any way suggesting
that Rick Scott stole this money. You know,
put that thought out of your head right now.
Right. That's probably the
safe thing to do. We shouldn't
we shouldn't jump to any conclusions. And by the
way, we're not. If Rick Scott had taken, you know,
$140 million from the Republicans, hundred and
45, I think is the exact number they'd know.
Right. There are receipts for these kinds of
things. Rick Scott could not have taken the money,
but he is bad with money. Okay. That's something
we can all pretty much agree on at this point.
So why in the heck Republicans decided to put this
guy in charge of the money? Still blows my mind.
Well, because he's independently wealthy has got
a net worth of hundreds of millions of dollars.
Would you think he was going to fill up your
campaign coffers with his own bank account? Heck,
no. Oh, because he knows a lot of rich
people. You all know a lot of rich people.
You didn't need him to be in this position.
And now you've put yourself in the position of
having a guy that already shouldn't have been
trusted with money. I mean, pleading the fifth 75
times that. That's 75 major red flags right there.
But you still looked at him and you said, you
know what, let's give him the purse strings.
Let's let him be the standard bearer for the
Republican Party and just spend our money,
do whatever. We've raised a lot of it. And now
in the final stretch of these midterm races.
Republicans are looking and saying, Oh, God.
We're out of money. We got to take a quick
break. I am Ferron cousins. If you want more from
me, you can find me on YouTube on my two channels,
YouTube.com, slash the ring of fire and
YouTube.com slash fair and balanced. I'm
also on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram
at Fair and balanced. This is the David
Pakman show unfair and cousins in for
David Pakman. And we'll be right back.